Surrounds us so profound,
90 to 98 percent,
that eight percent difference from thing
you read to the your raid is dark energy
or dark matter.
We don't know what it is.
We don't know what 98 percent of the
universe is and this wonderful man
Einstein,
this wonderful man who imagined the
scientific theories,
much like the Greeks who said,
all right,
if you cut something in half,
you've got to have the cut that half and
you keep going down the line.
You must come to the end and they said,
we'll call it an Adam,
and that's how they made their
scientific discoveries through the logic
of imagination.
Whereas we have tools to dimly dimly see
into the physical nature dimly see a
law.
Yeah.
That seems to be a law.
Wait a minute.
There's something here that counteracts
that law,
so just like our diets,
the pyramid,
carbohydrates,
a little bit of meat.
One day is 180 degrees reverse.
No,
no,
no.
What we meant was protein and a little
bit of carbohydrate.
Exactly.
One hundred 80 degrees different in your
diet.
That's what's happening in science all
the time.
There's a wonderful line science
scientists spread rumors.
We know everything is unified.
We know if we use our imagination like
the Greeks,
we look around us and we say the whole
world is unified.
Electrically.
Adams thing matter.
There's got to be a operating
the thing that has to be managed in some
way.
It's their.
Everything follows a logic.
We had these little instruments that
peer into the universe.
We're seeing a SPEC.
We're seeing a dust.
Mote
wouldn't the theory of everything.
Maybe you discover that as you die,
maybe as you die,
you though there's the theory of
everything.
Boom,
and you're dead.